it's a pleasure to be here on the
Stanford campus and talking to you all
about
I close to my heart a social
entrepreneurship Richard was mentioning
in terms of how India's got the current
head start in this domain but I think
necessary is the mother of invention
India is a country of 1.2 billion people
and a lot of problems with the
demographics their beer in terms of
power team in terms of illiteracy and so
forth so when you have so many problems
and at such a wide scale there is a
mattock processor set in motion to try
to kind of form solutions to those
problems and that's what yeah gives
India a kind of a unique role in this
domain I want to begin with just a quick
outline in terms of what I covered in
this talk and so I'm going to start by
mentioning some things about your action
for India and one of our key programs at
action for India creating a network of
hubs of social innovation then going to
give you a brief background in terms of
the status or the current state of
social enterprise solution price in
india and close by too quick topics one
in terms of how the work is in india is
actually relevant for social development
practitioners around the world not just
in india and how the people in this
audience can engage with our
organization so our core mission and
action for india is to work with social
innovators and by that i mean they could
be founders of for-profit social
enterprises or they could be founders of
not-for-profit NGOs but where they are
addressing critical social issues in
five sectors education health care
energy livelihoods and agriculture this
has kind of the usual suspect win-win
talks of social innovation social
entrepreneurship but what we do is we
identify what we refer to as poised to
scale social entrepreneurs in this five
sectors and then provide them give them
access to the resources that they need
and scaling up and this could be access
to funding access to mentorship access
to technology resources access to
government decision makers and access to
local partners or hub champions I'll
talk a little bit more about that our
inspiration is this gentleman
whose picture you see Sam Pitroda you
will be joining us in the talk later on
Sam Pitroda is currently the advisor to
the Prime Minister of India and he's the
chairman of India's national innovation
Council and back in the 1980s when he
was a member of the government of the
Union Cabinet of india with rajiv gandhi
is a prime minister he helped launch a
series of activities which in retrospect
came to be known as a telecom revolution
and today in india if you have 900
million cell phones for a population 1.2
billion people and one of the
fastest-growing telecom markets in the
world a lot of the credit can be traced
back to the work that Sam Pitroda did
back in the 80s and so I had met with
him at a alumni and iit alumni
conference in washington DC several
years ago had been loosely in touch with
them and the last couple of years those
interactions became more frequent and
focused leading to the current mission
of his organization and the launch of
our first event in january of two
thousand troops so we are a fairly
nascent organization about a year and
half fold but this is how it all began
and I should accept I mean I should
recognize acknowledge the connection
that action for India has to Stanford
among advisory board there at least four
individuals who are other current
Stanford faculty or who have been
Stanford allums on the left is Mark
granovetter is a chair of the department
of sociology on the right is Professor
hayagriva Rob is a professor and the GSB
and here you have Selenia courage it was
a Stanford MD and PhD is currently
general partnered so phenomenas it's a
biotech VC firm and at the bottom you
have GDS ramkumar who was again a PhD in
computer science and currently is an
entrepreneur with concept i oh so
there's been a yeah quite a bit of your
expertise and inside the drawn from
these individuals so I'm thankful to the
community that you all represent I just
want to take a minute to give you a
better context in terms of what action
for India is and what exactly we do I
did mention in the first slide but I
want to use yeah by way of explanation
this organization called rashtriya
schwoz the bima yojana rsby for shot so
rsby is a public-private partnership
between the government of india and
about 20 different private health
insurance companies it was founded by
this gentleman here anil soup is one of
the senior bureaucrats in india is part
of the Ministry of Labour in New Delhi
he started this initiative about four
years ago and there are a few
interesting things about his initiative
given that this program was targeting
poor people yeah who are mostly
illiterate they the founders of the
program they didn't want the
participants to fill up elaborate health
insurance forms or do signatures so they
designed the program to be completely
paperless and they also wanted to
minimize fraud in the system so what
happens is yep anybody who signs up for
the program he makes a one he or she
makes a one-time payment of 30 rupees
which is sixty cents and with that
payment they and a family of up to four
members gets access to health care
benefits up to 30,000 rupees or six
hundred dollars which is a pretty good
deal for the individual in the family
but the reason why that yeah it's so
attractive is because the government of
india heavily subsidizes this program
but the reason why the private health
insurance companies participate in a
program like this is because it makes
business sense for them to do so not
because it's a charity activity for lamb
that's the way the whole program has
been architected and that's interesting
in its own right so what happens is yeah
so I stole you that the program was
designed to be paperless it's also
designed to be cashless so apart from
the initial 30 rupees that the
participants give to the government
there's no other cash in the system so
how do you make a health insurance
program cashless and paperless so what
they do is they give the smart cards
with a chip embedded in it to each
participant so whenever these
participants you go to a hospital or a
clinic for treatment the card is fived
in the premises like a credit card and
all the transactions happen in the back
end so these are kind of interesting
things in their own right one of the
reasons I'm sharing this here at the
beginning of a presentation as the rsb
my initiative as a few attributes that
are aligned with a kind of work that we
are doing or we want to do more off
firstly its enabling this program is at
the core it's enabling social good at
the bottom of the pyramid basically poor
people are getting access to health care
benefits and that's a good thing
secondly this program is achieved rapid
scale in a short span of time the
programmers began as I said four years
ago and in this for years about 33
million smart cards have been
distributed among the population and
assuming a family size of four about 130
million Indians have come under the
umbrella of this program so even in a
country of 1.2 billion people this is a
non-trivial significant number and
thirdly bulk of this growth this rapid
growth has happened because of our SBA
founders were very particular about
leveraging technology to the health
right from the word go and in this case
smart card technology so action for
India being a year and a half old
organization has at nothing to do with
the success of this initiative but the
reason I share this is because what we
want to do or be an action for India is
to serve as a catalyst in the birth of
and growth of initiative like rsby which
embody these three characteristics and
again enable social good at the bottom
of grammar achieve rapid skin in a short
span of time and the organization uses
technology as pirates current business
model are as part of its future scaling
ambition so that's the kind of
organization that you want to work with
and help scale and as I mentioned in my
initial the thing so the five factors i
mean when social innovators are looking
to scale at the core of a domain is not
rocket science the meats that they have
are pretty kind of common sensical they
need funding they need Mentors they need
technology resources and government yeah
that's a touchy topic at least in the US
so one does not have to take money from
the government for your funding or what
have you but in the social sector
especially in India one cannot afford to
ignore the government because the
government is such a powerful
distribution channel for your products
and services you cannot achieve
significant scale unless you partner
with the government and interface with
the government at different levels and
finally local partners or web champions
so through that and i will be talking
electron we intend to give market
expansion opportunities to the
innovators in our network so these are
the different ways in which we work with
the social innovators and help them
scale so i want to start off yep by
giving you a few examples of some of the
innovators in india especially given
this is an audience which
knows the power of technology i have
chosen those organizations which have
integrated technology to their operating
and business models so this organization
gel do the founder is a gentleman by the
name Chandu chauhan he comes from the
western city of pune in india and he's a
very successful commercial entrepreneur
he runs a thousand crores or two hundred
million dollars annual revenue business
in india something called in a went f
and about three four years ago he got
interested in the social sector and
specifically in the domain of
purification of water and delivery of
purified water door-to-door so what he
does is he's got these pickup trucks or
three we go pick up trucks like the one
that you see in the picture and he's got
a large container there which has a
capacity for about 500 liters of water
and then he's got a state-of-the-art
filtration system which going to filters
bacteria virus arsenic fluoride and what
have you so basically what happens is
this vehicle can go to any source of
water it could be a bore well it could
be a pond lake so as long as the the
purification is kind of below a
particular threshold the impurities
below a particular threshold they can
pump the water from that source into
that container and they can use the
filtration system to do the purification
in situ on the vehicle itself and then
the vehicle can go door-to-door in the
area and kind of you have sell this
purified water so again water hear
people say that that the third world war
will not be fought for oil but will be
fought for water so this is increasingly
becoming a more serious problem and this
is in some sense yeah innovative
solution and actually the viability of
the business model of this believe it or
not is actually depends on a Jeep on an
algorithm which is going to kind of
optimize the routes that this vehicle
takes for delivery of the water so right
now he's in search for yeah kind of
refining that optimize algorithm which
will help him kind of reduces
transportation costs to make this a
viable business model so any of you who
are into optimization algorithm I'd love
to speak with you about this
then one here is Bhavani and so yet
she's a lady who works in the vocational
training space and she basically some of
you are in the computer science domain
you know of what the field of haptics is
H apt ICS it's the field of computer
human interface so she leverages the
principles of haptics and creates
virtual simulated environments through
which this whole vocational training can
be accelerated and can be scaled up so
one of the interesting things is doing
is the picture below you see or this
woman these women have been trained to
become plumber's in the state of Kerala
so normally when you want to train
anybody to become a plumber what do you
do you take them to the field you teach
them how to cut pipes or you teach them
how to fix a leaky faucet and that's how
they learn the trade but because of the
technology that is developed say that
the act of cutting a pipe you don't have
to take that person to the field you
don't have to have a hacksaw you don't
have to have a pike but in the computer
lab itself the person who is being
trained can experience the resistance
that one feels when you put the hacks
out of the pipe so what essentially all
this stuff does is it reduces the amount
of resources required to train a set
number of people and if the resource are
the same more number of people can be
taught things faster and in a country
like India we have 500 million people
are below 25 years of age and the
several tens of millions of jobs are
required each year something like this
can have great potential in terms of
training people faster and giving them
the jobs that they need on the right is
a new shreed run she's a Berkeley grad
who is now relegated to India and her
firm is something called next drop and
the very simple idea basically the water
supply that here which you take for
granted you have also apply 24 hours a
day seven days a week in India it's a
much more challenging thing especially
in the summers and when yeah things are
the monsoons haven't arrived on time and
thanks for that the water supply becomes
very haphazard random and people waste
lots of so the water supply is only an
particular windows of time and people
don't know when they're going to get
that water so people tend to waste lots
of time in terms of how these things
yeah in terms of collecting the water
that they need for the food and so forth
so she's developed some interesting
solutions leveraging the mobile platform
to reduce that winning time to make
things more predictable and she's turned
off with tyre three city and called
hubli and northwestern Attica and now
she's in process of raising funds to
kind of take it up to the national level
and other day one type of series and
this gentleman Sean blacks where is the
founder of a company called Baba job
bara job is an organization that you're
familiar with monster com in this
country it's basically if it is a job
matching site engineer project manager
salesman goes to go to that side to kind
of find relevant job opportunities so
what monster does for the professional
sector Baba job does for the informal
sector what do I mean by the informal
sector they could be cooks drivers rural
BPO entry-level workers and so forth
most of them are illiterate they can't
yeah do not have the computer literacy
to be able to kind of put their own
profiles online and so forth so what
they do is they've got this internet
kiosks where these people can go there
and submit basic information about
themselves for example imagine yeah that
this was going on in the Silicon Valley
so they give them yeah are they in Palo
Alto or the in the east bay or they in
San Francisco and so forth the location
where they want to kind of find the next
gig secondly the billing preferences
yeah do they want a ten dollars in our
job twenty dollars in our job or fifty
dollars in our job so basic information
and then in india as i mentioned to you
we have we are a country of 900 million
cell phones so almost everybody as a
cell phone and so as soon as a potential
employer csis a profile that matches
requirements a SMS is sent by bubba job
to that individual informing them about
it opportunity so again yeah so what
this is essentially doing is when people
have more opportunity for example take a
chauffeur the lots of shoppers and yeah
i mean that's not considered a luxury
like in this country that's more part of
their everyday like they're so they
if they were trying to look for a new
gig they'd restricted to the family life
family or friends or the neighborhood
that they operate in but because of this
technology now they have access to more
opportunities from around the country
around not only around the city so the
moment you have more opportunities it
improves your negotiating leverage it
improves your average daily incomes so
this is a fantastic example of how
technology is being used to make a
difference to people's lives at the
bottom the perimeter that's about a job
and finally digital green so digital
green is in the field of Agriculture so
the gentleman the founder reckon Gandhi
he is actually an MIT alum who went back
to indy about four years ago started
this yeah venture and basically what he
does is he goes to a rural area and
identifies a within quotes successful
farmer and then videotapes the farmer as
he is going about his business the
fertilizers that he uses the seeds that
he uses the irrigation method that uses
and so forth and then makes those videos
available to farmers in surrounding
villages that's the intervention but
that simple intervention has been proven
to be more significant in enhancing
agricultural productivity than anything
else that the government has done or
anything else that the multinational
organizations like United Nations has
done so this is at the core what it is
all about is in terms of assimilation of
best practices and yet the power of the
local network so if somebody were to do
this video's and northern part of India
say Kashmir and take those videos in the
southern part of India say kanyakumari
they would not be that much impact in
fact one of the first questions that
apparently Rickon gets asked when he
takes his videos is where is this farmer
whose videos you're showing me where is
he from so the hypothesis is that if if
this farmer in next door or next village
can do that why can't I do it and
therein lies the power of this idea real
quickly you've given us for really
interesting examples are these organized
as nonprofits or they organized as
regular companies I know digital green
is a not-for-profit organization okay it
was spun off as part of Microsoft
Research and Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation gave them a grand Bauer job
is a for-profit company and Vinod Khosla
social khosla impact has invested in
them and sorry bhavani the hamachi labs
is a not proper
it ok and I know drops I know she's
looking for a bunch of wine and she'll
be here next week actually ok so ho
that's the good mixer you know is AFI
providing mentoring to the show so each
one of these individuals are kind of
participants in our annual forums that
we don't talk about that in a minute and
for example with I know when she's going
to be here in the very next week I'm
going to be connecting her with some of
the investors angel investors in my
network and see if she can kind of get
if you're running right thank you ok and
so among the other things that we do so
I did give you a good glimpse in terms
of some of the members in our network
and from as part of the core programming
activity at action for India one of the
things that we do is organize this
annual forums so this year we organized
the forum in Delhi we had hundred of
these young innovators and you can
imagine what kind of yeah vibrations
could and atmosphere and enthusiasm
there would be when hundred of these get
together so adjoining them we're about
100 influences this include in a
investors donors public policy officials
government representatives and what have
you and with them where Sam Pitroda he
was there in person and members of the
national innovation Council and also mr.
days they spawned a i'll be talking
about him as well and so for a weekend
this entire community was engaged and
the whole theme was in terms of what are
the challenges that these innovators
face in scaling the impact of their
organizations and what role can
technology plain helping them scale what
role can government play in helping them
scale so that's the power of the forum
so we do this once every year the next
forum is coming up in january 2014 so if
any of you are in india and like to
attend do tok me a line these are some
pictures that we have and on the top
left you see about 10 of 10 20 of these
individual innovators so we go to great
lengths to source this hundred we have
partnerships with the who's who of
social on the participant india and so
we have filtering criteria to kind of
get to the hundred and within 100 before
the select ten of them two in each of
the five sectors and the given an
opportunity to share about the work that
they are doing and the innovation how
they're introducing innovation to the
sector so that's a picture there and
then we had a picture which was with
this deshpande at the center around my
nose
member of a Planning Commission and
shift came curves a senior industry list
so this was telecast on Bloomberg TV and
well the picture on the right is
generally the name Neil Patel he won a
growth price that we kind of awarded
he's a Stanford PhD in computer science
is doing some very interesting things in
the agriculture domain and so forth so
this is the growth place that I talked
about so we worked on this competition
along with Ashoka this is the global
network of social entrepreneurship
Darlene come on shoka here so we kind of
monitor the progress about 60 to 70
different organizations across this five
sectors and then we had mr. Deshpande
mr. pitroda mr. Anand Mahindra Sagira
here at Stanford these were all and
sushi that goes from Ashoka they're all
members of the jury to kind of determine
who were going to be the winners of this
good price competition and we plan to
kind of continue this in the coming
years as well so some of the other
projects so in addition to the annual
forum the mentorship network as I said
yeah having opportunity to find the
right mentors who can guide them in the
scaling efforts is key so we are
planning to kind of use an online
platform and we have a Silicon Valley
Chapter four action for India and the
lot of as you know the valley is home to
a large concentration of Indian origin
entrepreneurs executors investors and
lot of them have an urge to kind of
contribute back to India and connect
with what's happening there so we'd like
to leverage a mentoring platform to get
their time tu mente some of the social
innovators in India we have a debt
financing advisory service we have kind
of partnered with some public sector
banks in India and we are off we are
going to offer collateral free
low-interest bank loans to some of the
selected innovators in a network and
then a online learning community again
facilitate yeah through platforms like
WebEx or what have you one too many
mentorship opportunities where a
particular individual depending on his
expertise speed in terms of customer
acquisition distribution social media
what have you on topics of relevance to
the social innovators they're able to
share their expertise so yeah this is
the next section is about a key
programmatic focus area of action for
India and I want to talk about
what is kind of the again inspiration
for this program the gentleman that you
see there is this deshpande how many in
this room have heard about this planet
before okay a few hands I just want to
take a minute to mention a little bit
more about him he is one of the most
successful indian-origin entrepreneurs
or even the entrepreneur period in the
US he's based in Boston is a telecom guy
his phone at least three firms which all
went to north of billion-dollar market
caps in the market valuation and he sits
on the board of MIT and he President
Obama I selected him to be a co-chair
for the Council on innovation and
entrepreneurship it's a 30-member
organization and its co-chaired the
other co-chair as Steve Case the founder
of AOL so that's the background but the
reason I include him here is he's doing
some very interesting things back in
India so he comes from this home state
of Karnataka bangla is the capital city
of Karnataka so he as he and his wife
jaishree through the deshpande
foundation have been doing an experiment
in that region of Karnataka it's called
the experiment the project is called the
sandbox so they beam they initiated this
project five years ago so basically what
they do is they beam I mean pumping
about three to four million dollars
every year and that money is used to
support the work about 8,200 different
social organizations in four sectors
education healthcare livelihoods
agriculture so even though they are
doing the work in a particular region of
India deshpande doesn't view this as a
regional development initiative is not
doing this just because hubli is a
native place and everything is fine
isn't hubli than everything in spite of
the world but he's using this because
but it treats this as a social
innovation lab and by that what I mean
is that yeah so he identifies
organizations of potential and whichever
organizations are thriving he kind of
closely monitors the progress and pumps
an additional resource of the scale to
the national and international level the
admirable thing of what this man is
doing with the sandbox is this trying to
bring in the best practices of the
business world into the not-for-profit
word and
just want to share with you two
organizations that I've thrived in that
sandbox one of them is this organization
called Agastya so against Thea is
basically a program that promotes
scientific curiosity in rural
underprivileged kids and so they have
this mobile vans which have equipment to
do experiments in sat in chemistry
physics astronomy and so forth and these
vans go from school to school village to
village and in a three-hour period about
200 experiments or show quiz to the
students so this program is actually
having impact some of you in the room
might know about the Intel Science
Talent Search exam in this country so
that's primarily to identify research
prowess in undergraduate student in high
school students in this country so they
have a regional counterpart to this exam
in India and in the last few years among
the top ten winners at least four of
them have been alumni of this I guess
their program so it's not that just in a
three a program by watching a three hour
show they are beginning geniuses but I
guess Thea organizes they do some
follow-up work beyond that initial
program and so it's having a lot of
impact when people say in the social
element world that don't give a man a
fish teach him how to fish but here
what's happening is you are igniting the
spark of creativity imagination in these
children and once that spark is ignited
people do not go back to the original
state so the long-term impact of a
program like this is yeah invariable
secondly is this organization called
akshaya patra and again how many in the
room have heard about this program okay
this one too then okay so this is again
quickly it's a program to feed midday
meals to school children in government
schools in India and so a lot of poverty
especially in rural India so people
don't even send the kids to school they
want them on their family land to help
with agriculture and so forth so this is
a effort to get schools to get children
to schools with the promise of giving
them a one full meal in a day and the
hope is that once they come to school
they're also attend some classes and
pick something along the way so this
program was begun by the hurry Rama Hari
Krishna folks the iskcon folks about ten
years ago they started
feeding about thousand kids in schools
in and around bangalore now ten years
later after coming under the umbrella of
the sandbox the program feeds 1.3
million kids every day in 20 locations
around the country and that kind of
scale doesn't happen randomly there are
as I said best practices so if you walk
into a kitchen in hubli it's probably if
not the world's largest single kitchen
at least Asia's largest single kitchen
there are the stall towers that you see
you feels as if you walk into a
petroleum refinery one tower is
separating the rice from the stones one
tower is boring the rice bowling the one
tire is boring the samba they've
automated the packing of the meals and
they got the average cost of the meal
down to about five apiece or ten cents a
meal and they do a lot of fundraising
here in the US a twenty eight dollar
donation feeds one kid for an entire
year in India so this program came to
the attention of President Bill Clinton
a few years ago those are this massive
earthquake earthquake in Haiti and so
President Clinton was the head of the
relief efforts there and there was a
requirement for ya similar kitchens
where low cost quality means to be
disseminated in a fast manner so
President Clinton took mr. Deshpande
along with him to Haiti to see if
similar kitchens as the one who blew
could be set up for the faster
dissemination of meals and so these are
the kind of programs that are thriving
in the sandbox and what we at action for
India done recently is we have signed a
memorandum of understanding with the
deshpande foundation and the Memorandum
of Understanding enables us through that
we are going to evangelize or promote
this concept of a regional hub of social
innovation and we are going to identify
champions who are going to Shepherd
these regional hubs in different parts
of the country and they're going to
commit financial and in-kind resources
to launch and maintain the subs and the
eventual vision of this program is to
have a learning network of these
regional hubs around the country where
in the best practices of one hub would
flow into the other and they by the
broader socio-economic durban of the
country could be accelerated this is
kind of the really ambitious agenda
ambitious vision but at the core when
you talk of setting up a new hub what
does it mean so first thing you do a
reconnaissance of that region whatever
new region that you pick up so what are
the
expressing gaps in that region is it
educate in education what is the problem
that 8th grade students are dropping out
of school in health care is the mothers
mortality during child by the problem or
so you identify the most pressing
problems and the second step that you do
is you look at your existing network of
social innovators and you try to figure
out who are the social innovators who
already develop solutions or products to
address the gaps of that region and you
try to reduce the friction or provide
incentives for this innovators to come
to the region to make a difference to
the problem and finally the third point
which is the most important at least in
mr. Deshpande is mine is to create a
learning or yeah a nurturing environment
of a natural ecosystem where some of the
local population gets inspired and they
become innovators themselves because if
you depend on outsiders coming in for a
short span of time that changes never
really sustainable you need to have the
local population invested and involved
in developing solutions so that is the
third step so we have already yeah
identified about I just come to this in
a million so there are about five
locations we've already identified in
different parts of the country to in
north india three in south india so
we've got in north india in delhi the
dealer foundation which is india's
largest real estate company and then we
have the lip mori who is a telecom on
spooner in the western state of Uttar
Pradesh we have Raju ready from who's a
Silicon Valley successful entrepreneur
who's from the state of Andhra Pradesh
anism bad and the srini Raju who runs a
1.2 billion dollar private equity fund
from Hyderabad so he's promoting a new
city called 3 city in on the padishah
again and finally sangeetha ready from
chittoor district she is one of the
directors at apollo hospitals it's part
of the founding family it Apollo
Hospital is the nation's largest network
of hospitals in India so we've got
individuals who have the financial
wherewithal and who got the social
commitment to adopt these regions and
help launch a region have the social
innovation in those regions and so this
is gives you a model in terms of how the
hub would work so you've got action for
India in the middle there are the
financial resources it could be
philanthropic resources so the low
partners or the cooperate houses with
the CSR funds and the government could
have some of the innovation funds coming
into the region excuse me and then we
have the resources so they spawned a
foundation is a knowledge partner
they've been at it for the last five
years they know what works what doesn't
work in a region and there'll be a lot
of customization with each new hub but
some of those learnings could be
leveraged to make things faster cheaper
better and so that's kind of the
non-financial kind of resources and yeah
we try to kind of endless the social
innovators are going to come to the
region we increase another local talent
to become innovators and this in the end
leads to social economic development in
the targeted area but again I should
kind of mention that these things are
not a month-long projects or a quarter
la corte long projects it takes three
years five years eight years before
there is any significant difference in
the social indicators of the region so
it's a need to be patient with how
things happen there these are some of
the partners here and yeah just closing
out on this and we want to get the
support of different people yeah they
could be high net worth individuals they
could be CS our departments who
cooperates there could be foundations or
they could be government departments so
in the past for the two forum that
you've held we've had the deshpande
foundation they had nokia into
hewlett-packard those kind of
organizations have supported as I said
form partnerships with the Hoos ooh in
India in social entrepreneurship beat
the iit alumni with the deshpande
foundation the NASSCOM foundation so
forth so it's been a this kind of work
cannot be done alone so the
collaboration is the key and we've been
proactive in reaching out to all the
various partners and I will skip this
I'll skip the social and present India I
just want to since in the interest of
time have making a work-relevant
globally so what is happening in India
is not relevant just for India alone
some of these ideas be in terms of
frugal innovation being able to kind of
develop products of solutions at a
fraction of the cause that are available
elsewhere in the world that is something
I think would be relevant to people not
just in India but yeah people in beta
Africa Latin America or other parts of
Asia so the sandbox that I talk to you
about in northwest karnataka the five
years of
there have given enough insights that
they spanned a foundation has opened a
new sandbox in Merrimack Valley this is
in the suburbs of boston and there we
were trying to do something in louisiana
they already doing something in canada
so the innovation lab that was set up in
hubli is giving a fountain of insights
which are being replicated or customized
in other parts of the world so it is
useful to kind of ya think in terms of
how closely following the work studying
the work in this sector in india would
be relevant and useful to people even
here I talk to you about Akshay pather
about the haiti how President Clinton
actually was taking this this money to
haiti digital green i mentioned to you
about the work in being done in
agriculture so he's already been the
work that he's done in the states of
india now he's going to different parts
of africa and even China was hearing him
say that a couple of weeks ago he was in
China and they're trying to see if
similar things can be done in China so
it's finding global opportunities for
replication and not just in India and
yeah so the last light of my
presentation is how you can get involved
and again so you're right here in the
valley and the valley is the center of
its epicenter of technology innovation
for the universe so one clear dimension
in which you could potentially engage
with the innovators in a network is to
kind of yeah look at the problem that
they're trying to solve look at the
technologies that you have access to in
your domain of work and see if there's
any overlap in which your technologies
can help make things faster cheaper
better for them then there is a
mentorship piece as I said you don't
have to be physically present in India
to be able to come into these people
we've got online platforms nowadays your
skype or WebEx even just a phone call
could be able to get people connected so
depending on your sector of interest me
to education health care energy we'd be
happy to for those interested make the
necessary connections with innovators in
that sector and the funding of course so
the funding could be equity funding it
could be grant funding it would be dead
funding so one potential thing if you're
interested in making angel investments
that could be again an opportunity I
told you
a new reader in the Berkeley grad with
the organization next drop so she's
trying to raise money for expanding our
organizations in India so this is not
charity so if you invest in our
organization it's a financial
transaction not only do you have the
satisfaction in terms of engaging the
project which enable social good but
also get financial returns for your
project then we talked about a
technology working with government
friendly so I think yeah from here yet
there are organizations like us eight
for instance which supports projects all
around the world not just in us so they
could be opportunities for some of these
government agencies to engage with the
innovators there and finally the hub
champions so there would be
opportunities as I said there's we are
trying to build this network of this
regional hubs of social innovation and
so if you are interested you could in
turn with action for India and set up
time to actually relocate yourself for
three months six months nine months and
then help oversee some of these work
with the social areas are doing in the
region so that's another opportunity so
with that I'll stop yeah I know that
every no Sanjay that's that's fantastic
if I can ask radical to join us up on
stage and woke up no please okay now
we're going to do the panel discussion
part of this Radhika tell us a little
bit about the Silicon Valley Chapter and
also introduce yourself while I try to
get the next set set up okay yeah so I'm
a Stanford alum computer science
department from a while ago pleasure to
be back at my alma mater and I'm a
high-tech entrepreneur been in the high
tech space be companies small companies
early days of the internet exciting
times here and about four or five years
ago I got very interested in the world
of social causes social entrepreneurship
and involved in a few organizations in
the education human rights livelihood
space and also very involved in
mentoring an active mentor at startx and
the skydeck labs Berkeley I just like to
mention that Jeffrey Jeff burns Jeff
Burton here with skydeck slabs is here
and amazing social entrepreneur go Nita
from Berkeley and they're doing amazing
stuff there as well and then we have
some statics mentees here so with that I
will talk a little bit about the chapter
here that we're looking at setting up
we've been looking at engaging Silicon
Valley resources to help AF
what we learnt in some of the other
social causes were engaged with
including a group called Rajiv circle
that George Gregory is here with us it's
a mentoring group in memory of Stanford
professor RG mitrani that we started is
that there is a lot of enthusiasm and
energy in the valley among the brilliant
technologist students professors
entrepreneurs to help social causes and
if there is a way to create a community
to facilitate engagement and pull these
people together in one group amazing
things come out out-of-the-box ideas
come out and so we're hoping to do that
with AFI here both in terms of
volunteering with the project's their
brainstorming on interesting ideas we
there is groups like samasource here
that are leveraging digital technology
in amazing ways to help provide
livelihood to place a sub-saharan Africa
India and such goonie Tahir is creating
an archive of stories of 1947 partition
of India to help build empathy globally
so it is amazing what you can do with
technology and then there is also
resources and have the financial
resources that Thunder talked about but
what we would like to do is build a
community around AFI and the social
entrepreneurship and see at a meet
periodically and then tap into whatever
people here would be interested in doing
weather is engaging with the group's
they're brainstorming on ideas coming up
with new models and also solving some of
the really really complex challenges
around scaling social entrepreneurship
in places like India the very unique
challenges and get time we'll talk a bit
about that the other unique challenge is
distribution one of the biggest
challenge in addressing bottom of the
pyramid markets is how do you scale
distribution when the end user you might
be in some remote village the / cost
that you will make this is for social
entrepreneurs you are looking at
for-profit models as well as nonprofit
how do you actually get to that user in
a cost effective manner and then also
coming up with very novel models to
leverage technology so we're looking at
a wide range of things and with that
since you would you like to add a bit
about what so again as I was mentioning
we launched the Silicon Valley Chapter
last fall and the whole premise of
starting this was that there is a huge
concentration of
indian-origin successful entrepreneurs
and investors and executives and in
addition to that as I said the valley
from people around the world there's a
huge diversity and in terms of
technology innovation that's at from
this region and goes to different parts
of the world we felt that there'd be
married and starting having our chapter
here so to leverage these resources that
we have here and connect them with the
social innovators in India beat as
mentors beat as investors or what
happened so Radhika can I ask kind of a
the severe question so even worse than
money the thing that really doesn't
scale is time and when you put your
resources in your contacts behind a
particular initiative or an organization
there's a huge opportunity cost for what
you're not doing with that time what was
it that made you think AFI was the way
that you should get become more involved
with this sure so one of the things that
really appeals to me and I think will
help you to a lot of people here is how
far the time you put in what is the
impact of that and the fact that this is
a meta-level system that helps so many
social entrepreneur scale is what drew
me when I might send you about a year
ago so while it is very satisfying to
one work one-on-one with entrepreneur
focus on a deep claws no it is also
satisfying to have impact at a large
scale especially with technology
technology is my passion and many of us
here and leveraging technology in a way
where you can impact many people across
the world many social entrepreneurs who
can then have large scale impact here's
what drew me to AFI ok and so kind of
following up on that Sanjay when we
talked by phone earlier this week you
were saying that really AFI is kind of
like ty for social ventures and social
innovation right the indus entrepreneurs
which is a huge organization it's got
55,000 members all over the world and
our way 15 20 what hi folks I thought it
was even more than that all over the
world individuals who are involved right
but in any case how did how did you feel
that there was a need to have a fi I
mean India has gone
and a lot of these are great ventures
and there's been a lot of support for
bottom of the pyramid kind of work and
in India what was it that led you to
feel that this was a really big need
sure so again to those of you not
familiar with tie it stands with the
indus entrepreneurs it's a global
network about 17 countries 60 chapters
around the world and about 15,000 20,000
members so they are a platform for
fostering entrepreneurship mentoring
entrepreneurs so this is for primarily
for for-profit entrepreneurs and when I
was yep looking at the domain or the
space of social innovation social
enforcement India they were yes so many
challenges affecting the entrepreneur's
there were long people willing to walk
away from lucrative carries the private
sector but even I mean yeah they
identified problems they came up with
solutions they express commitment in
terms of pursuing them but then there
was time ed it in terms of lack of
funding beer in terms of not having
access to the right technology solutions
beat government regulations that were
kind of becoming constraints so I felt
that yeah if there could be one similar
platform where people could come
together you give them opportunity to
collaborate with each other and you get
the best of breed innovators into the
network and people with access to
government for example Sam Pitroda is
the advisor to the Prime Minister of
India and mr. days deshpande is an
advisor to President Barack Obama so
people have their stay so merit in this
effort and I felt that yeah with those
kind of resources in place we could make
a dent you came at it really from the
angle of being an impact investor as
well as an entrepreneur right uh yeah so
for my travel back right I go right what
do you think is it time can we try
calling Sam five showed us so it's still
a few minutes early should i give them
another friend
if he's on skype this chick right now he
shows up with a question mark okay oh so
I'm not sure if you're given my online
he says he just said a minute ago he's
online yes yeah okay yeah yeah he hasn't
he interacts with my contract yeah
predictor how much time we make voting
each week to this activity either
without other social optionrally fifteen
percent of my cell phone you accept that
invitation on sound also quite a bit on
mentoring as about yeah Sam this is
Richard dash are calling it from
Stanford yes sir how are you thank you
very much I can hear you well let me
just but I can't see you that well
because your roof yeah I can see you
better okay thank you and what I'm going
to do after we make sure that this is
working well as I'm going to turn around
so you can see the people in the
auditorium I'll just move my laptop in
the other direction can you send us a
video i am just sending it's just
setting it on but not going to yeah
maybe it could be that our connection
isn't quite live yet thank you very much
for joining us today by the way welcome
but let's hope that this thing works
normally once yeah we usually been
pretty fortunate with this in fact just
last week I called him from Tokyo Japan
I do cannot be the veek okay okay okay
so you know sometimes in my office they
play with my computer please upgrade
that so Sam we've had a wonderful
introduction to your background and who
you are tell us why you think AFI is
important in what are your main hopes
for this organization I think the idea
of AFI is to really bring together young
talent interested in social ventures in
social innovations idea is to provide a
platform for young people to come
interact learn and see how they can make
a contribution let me do this let me
reset my computer okay shall I hang up
for a second you can talk here for a
minute well I'll hang up and we'll try
this again in a second bye for now so
yeah we take a quick minute to talk
about Sam again here for those of you
who don't know much about him I did
mention something at the beginning to
his current roles our advisor to the
Prime Minister of India chairman of
India's national innovation Council and
so back I think in the 1960s just like
most of the other Indians in this
country he finished his yeah I think
undergraduate studies in India then came
here for his graduate studies he was
studying at the illinois institute of
technology in chicago then he became a
that's the other IIT exactly it sure and
then you work in a couple of telecom
companies i think Rockwell was one of
them and then after getting some
experience in fact he had a start-up and
the value of him are mistaken became a
successful serial entrepreneur a
self-made millionaire and then in one of
his trips to India I think this was in
the early 80s he this is much earlier
before cellphones and before all this
skype and all that stuff he was trying
to make a call to his wife here in the
US and for whatever reason that call
yeah it took him a long time to kind of
make the connection happen and that is
what was the trigger oh so some things
are not really changed it is what you're
I'm gonna take a quick question about
something else before we bring Sam back
okay um you gave a number of examples
about projects from India that have been
applied outside India deck what do you
see is the biggest challenges for our
localization in regard to doing this
kind of social innovation so how do you
make donato not only from in different
places inside India but how do you take
these on a worldwide scale so mr.
Deshpande tries to mention that yeah one
of the most important things in the
social innovations Spheeris you need to
kind of become completely attuned with
that local environment unless you really
understand the problem to the region and
not you can't do that kind of remotely
kind of setting 20,000 miles away you
can be theorizing intellectualizing
about things you need to kind of immerse
yourself in that local environment and
then yeah the be technology of it
everything else comes later but granular
understanding of the problem is most
important and I think that's the one
step in a rush to kind of optimized and
accelerate things that's mess and that's
what leads to obstacles in successful
replication okay let me try say I'm
again okay and Sam is 70 years old he's
at to quadruple bypass surgeries his
survived cancer but he still has the
energy of a 25 year old person he is
correct yank team of people who always
find it difficult to kind of keep up
with him this is amazing in terms of his
energy levels their kitchens Godfather
of India's oh yeah so he's that
considered the father of modern Indian
telecom as I mentioned I mean he
organized he founded these two
organizations one was C dot center for
development of telematics and one was
c-dac Center for development of advanced
computing these are the organizations
which sowed the seeds for ya what led to
the research development of indigenous
technology telecom technology and now
all the work manager main cell phones
for one purple in people didn't quite
get an answer this time we'll see one
more time a blue tonight it's probably
still rebooting his computer
aha ok that's a good time ok hi Sam yes
sir ready my camera speed goes on our
yeah oh it's great to hear you I'm glad
you can join us by audio maybe I can ask
you to give a few remarks to everybody
here yeah yeah even though we don't have
the video link ok i can start first by
thanking everybody good evening everyone
good evening thank you for giving me
this opportunity ninety-nine percent of
the time this thing works once in a
while he doesn't my apology i had too
many meetings today so i just didn't get
a chance to kept it I'm delighted to
meet you and I will kind budget for
organizing this the group dance and I
work together really focuses on social
innovation as you know India has 550
million young below age of 25 we have
huge amount of challenges related to
disparity disparity between ditchin were
urban rural education as educators and
we also have to expedite the process of
modernization development and in the
process we have to make sure that this
growth is including and focuses more on
what about the economics of it to do lot
of these things we believe we need to
take advantage of the technology
mainly information in communications
also by all that nanotech material or
energy and we also need to innovate we
need to innovate to create new business
models for education health public
services agriculture energy because we
realize that the existing models are
expensive and difficult to scale for us
because we need to focus on
affordability skill LED and
sustainability so technology is
definitely going to play an important
role in many of these areas so well
because we have today is to democratize
information to take information to
people to empower them and we are
winning massive networks to democratize
information as you know not long ago we
had two million telephones in India it
used to take 10 years to get a telephone
connection today we have 900 million
mobile phones we are a nation of a
collective opinion and we need to take
this connectivity forward to really
bring about generational change in way
we do things so we are spending lot of
money in creating broadband
infrastructure using fiber to connect
all our universities lotteries are any
institutions on our local governments
250,000 it is going to require about
450,000 philosopher of optical
fiber in addition to the million
kilometer we already have then we are
creating that fast for you i D GI as
payment if you are and we believe was
the information gets democratized will
begin to focus on innovative ideas for
the bottom of the eeprom experience
again this would relate to education
health agriculture farmers financial
services governments and a lot of young
people are already thinking about these
things our needs are very good mainly
because we have a large population we
need to lower down the cost of delivery
service us and we believe because of
cloud computing open source software
generic drugs and many other unique
opportunities given open drug discovery
platform give it a floral foam
government is trying to create friendly
policies but it takes time it takes time
to go from the old mindset to the new
mindset I feel very optimistic because
we have huge amount of potential young
talent I said many many times that the
best brains in the world are busy
solving problems of the rich who really
don't have problems to solve and as a
result problems of the four really don't
get the right kind of tunnel we have the
largest number of food in the world and
we have moral responsibility to address
the problem
and that's what we are trying to do it
not going to have a 49 these things take
decades but our journey has just started
and what's a jay is doing at action for
it relates to bring in young talent
together and address the challenges of
the bottom of the economic pyramid
several ventures and already shown us
that it is possible to do it Robert is
quite encouraged with the results plc
and we've got young entrepreneurs to
come help us to be that the basic
message it is we can probably open up
sorts of discussions once again and yet
in the professor for giving me this
opportunity I want to apologize for not
going to be but at least I can see you
all I'm happy to accept thank you Sam
thank you very much and your message
comes through loud and clear even if we
didn't have a video image to accompany
it would you be willing to stay for a
few questions yes that I really liked it
okay I have a question for the whole
panel and then we'll open it up to the
audience the whole idea of
sustainability when it comes to social
innovation is a little different than it
is in other areas of entrepreneurship
because in other areas of
entrepreneurship you have a clear exit
where the original people basically sell
their stock including the founders
because after a company goes public the
founder is working for a public company
not their own company and I would like
to ask what you see is the best model
for long term sustainability for a
social venture Sam let me ask you to go
first sure I think social venture does
not necessarily imply donations social
ventures have to have a business model
to sustain profits may not be thirty
percent forty percent profit will not be
on a quarter-to-quarter basis equity may
not come from venture capitalists only
it could come from you know trust
government it could get some subsidy but
at the end of the day it has to have a
business model with some bottom line
profit to feed it back into it otherwise
it is not sustainable the Social Venture
is profitable and sustainable you might
be able to sell it to somebody to a
bigger social venture you might be able
to take in public they not have the same
value and ratios but it's wrong to
assume that social ventures imply always
donations okay thank you that's why I
appreciate that sunshine what would you
say sure so all of these homeowners two
of them where the for-profit variety and
two of them with a not-for-profit kind
so a digital green in that rickety
domain was being supported by currently
a 10 million dollar grant from the
berlin between the Gates Foundation
whereas baba job in bangalore trying to
help these Rubio internal workers or
domestic staff for the informal sector
that was a for profit venture and right
here in the valley khosla ventures their
social impact division was funding them
so it's not so much in terms of here was
a market-based solution or not as long
as the entrepreneur and the organization
is able to condemn on straight value to
the target audience I think as long as
that the quality of the the value
addition is positive I think things can
sustain will even writing in the valley
everybody has read about some mark on
and the Khan Academy and there it could
have gone either way but I think Bill
Gates gave a donation or yeah John doar
game iteration and he chose not to go
the market-based solution and he found
that that was a better route to
sustainability then going to the my best
solution so my own view is that it's not
a question of yeah I could lean on
equity exit not exit it's a question of
in terms of what value as the
entrepreneur and his firm give to the
interrogatories radical what do you look
at for this sure so after around the
question a bit and because I have
thought about this discusses a lot with
people and I think it is in the interest
of most social causes to think
sustainability because this is really
hard to raise donations and just be
dependent on others right yeah and so
I'm summer source is one example right
on the way to sustainability they have a
model and they're doing something that
is possible to generate revenues that
said there are some causes such as
infant mortality human rights what guna
tha's doing right that is really really
hard to make them sustainable and I'm on
the board of a nonprofit that helps the
rural girls in Mozambique pull them out
of the cycle of exploitation and get
them into this elementary schools we've
looked at models of sustainability women
looked at the girls can make some crafts
but it was very very hard so I'm not
convinced every social venture can be
sustainable but what I've seen is if
they're not it's a constant constant
challenge okay thank you and there are
some calls is that just require can
constant effort yeah ok let's open the
floor
you're honest George Gregory and that I
have a question for for the panel you
know what is your view on the actually
following up on sustainability right
so what is your view on the
emerging structures in business
specifically benefits corporation that's
in many states now it became I became
available in Abby Court which is kind of
a week of orbit which allows you know
for-profit venturers essentially to you
know it to a lot to introduce uh you
know social benefit as the reason for
existence of the corporation in addition
you need anything no it's great that you
bring this up because this is a
relatively new type of company in the
United States it's recognized state by
state and right now I think there's 15
or 20 states that recognize what are
called be corpse they are technically
for-profit corporations that in their
board in their bylaws state that all or
part of their profits are going to be
put back into nonprofit causes this
allows the board of directors not to be
sued by stockholders who are unhappy
with less than a highest return on the
funding and you know this has had an
impact although it takes quite a lot to
be formally recognized as a B Corp you
actually have to pass several different
tests but for the panel I think the
question is when you're looking at a new
social venture how do you decide to
determine whether it should be a
non-profit or a B Corp or whether it
should just be volunteer activities that
doesn't require a legal entity I think
it would depend this is Sam it depends
on the kind of activities who are
involved if it is related to infant
mortality you may have expensive cell
which may have you may have some
profitability cod sorry about that
screensaver can you hear me yes my
screensaver just came in I've got I
forgot to turn it off okay so the point
is it all depends
I think we can't get locked up in one
model or the other models when it comes
to social venture it will be this and
that and some more and we'll have to
experiment but the fact is that you will
not expect the kind of returns that you
probably expect out of a normal venture
that's given so if you're expecting
twenty percent iono don't get involved
in social right are there other things
you shouldn't expect if you get involved
in the social venture Sanjay would you
like to take this one yes for India as I
said yeah the various inputs of you try
to provide to the entrepreneur's be in
terms of access to funding estimators
one mandate that you've taken about
assets is to serve as an interface
between public policy and Social
Innovation idea so again most of these
innovators is on Spooner's the cell they
have said no to be kind of curious in
the private sector they are identified
problems they've come up with solutions
for them the explicit commitment in
pursuing them so the government should
also come halfway in terms of helping
them in terms of removing regulatory
hurdles or obstacles are giving them
more pathways and making it easier
cutting the red tape so that yeah the
effort that they put in yeah is this
some level of rigor not necessary
financial bind up so even from an impact
basis so be cope is something that's
going to get into action here in the US
and in an earlier forum in India this is
this very issue came up in our
discussions with the entrepreneurs they
wanted the Government of India who takes
steps in terms of making this become
possible the sexy possible in India as
well and we will work with the
government in trying to see what can
happen in terms of isolating Oh
expanding that Radhika in your
experience have you seen a lot of uptick
in the number of social ventures that
are being proposed in recent years in a
rapid increase in the number of social
ventures that are that you here
about these days my social ventures are
you talking on for profits or just
social causes social causes I do see
many more at least my I'm my perspective
is from silicon valley-based Lloyd and I
do come across more and more and also
see many which kind of overlap that
people are building very interesting
technology startups with a clear
for-profit business model and the very
interested in social impact so I see a
lot of hybrids and I also see a lot of
nonprofits and I just wanted to add one
point of the previous question if I may
that I think to some degree it matters a
lot on where the entrepreneurs coming
from then what is their intrinsic
motivator and clear trade-off of SM was
saying there is no one fixed model but
what works for each group each cause
Annie's human being may vary then having
brutal intellectual honesty and what
will it take to execute if you just want
to do a non-profit but you don't think
about what I'll take to raise donations
right thinking through some of those
might be very helpful then on that
Salman Khan he when he shares his life
story it's very relevant to this point
he had the ability to do a for-profit
the reason he chose a non-profit in his
case is he felt he could execute way
more effectively oh and he was okay
doing both models but the resources he
could harness that way seemed like that
would help him execute is one of the
story share so glad that thank you we
have several hands oh sorry let me ask
you to go first Sam one of the things
that caught my attention was you had
noted that there are public models in
India where there is demonstrated
efficiency of social execution and
therefore learnings to be had and of
course on Jane is talked earlier on
talked about the sandbox approach to
what the dash Pandey foundation is doing
in order to produce aggregated social
innovation across organizations provide
ecosystem benefits can you share with us
a couple of examples either in India or
otherwise where there are clear examples
of sharing models of innovation because
these are not well talked about unlike
private markets which are talked about
in business schools and other forums
social innovation business models are
often not much in vogue so I'm curious
whether you could share a couple of
examples Sam could you understand that
question could you hear from where you
are okay too early but with the same
time rumbles in many many examples that
one could look at take for example dr.
David shetty in bangalore who provides
quadruple bypass for two thousand
dollars now this has been proven he
doesn't day in day out and he is now
going to shut up a hospital in Canadian
with 1200 beds for the US market to go
from fifty to eighty thousand dollars
for bypass the two thousand is a huge
difference similarly I mean I can
provide cataract bypass a candidate
surgery for two dollars there are ten
examples like this in India that we know
of whether it is joyful foot these are
all well-known examples and there are
some not very well known whether it is
sort of fuel for cooking and a very low
cost or a cooling refrigerator at twenty
dollars so these examples are already
there but it is too early because the
history of social metrics is very do it
doesn't have any enough you know 50 or
100 your data to back it out so you
don't eat to have all the answers I
think it's you know those who are
looking for all the answers will not
find all the answers so some people will
be comfortable with less answers others
would be not very African
so those are comfortable won't get into
it you know and those were comfortably a
few answers we can influence so I don't
think social rented it for everybody you
know ok I think that's an excellent
point what you really need is the
business model that works for your
Venture and you know to a certain extent
if you find things that are out there
that are useful great but you may have
to be clever and discover a new one
absolutely let's do one more question go
ahead he mentioned that a lot of the
people behind the organizations that
you're backing have kind of turned down
lucrative job opportunities in Silicon
Valley and other high-tech places but it
seems like relying on that is not the
most sustainable option because really
the people who are most motivated to
start these kinds of ventures are the
people who are living in those
circumstances in the first place I would
think so have you done anything to back
people who are actually coming out of
the underprivileged communities that
they're serving and and kind of educate
look bridge the the education gap and
help them get something started kind of
from the place that they would
eventually be serving rather than
turning away from a a more you know
first world career option in the first
place that done is not on Valley that is
all over the world maybe different
degree we have in Kerala a startup
village where government has given about
100,000 square feet facility with power
you know lips paper and all at
we are people start methods we have
already started about three hundred
venture three hundred and many are
successful one company is already worth
about thirty forty million dollars here
from scratch these are all young people
I went there myself most of them
basically live there it grew her early
twenties in there are doing some play
into the working at the date of us the
smartest hacker in here is a guide from
Bihar 15 year old who father is a peon
so there are all kinds of examples it
again it's not that we are expecting
Silicon Valley fellows to live there you
know 200,000 our job info and service
India but it is good to be connected it
is good to interact it is good to learn
and that's what these exercises all
about ok Sam thank you i want to add
sanjay to a comment briefly how is AFI
going to try to bring up on
entrepreneurs social entrepreneurs from
the bottom of the pyramid sure so
internet when i was talking to you about
the they spawned a foundations model the
sandbox model and how AFI was fine will
replicate those regions of social
innovation around the country I told you
they were essentially three steps and
the third step in there was actually
trying to make efforts focus your
efforts in terms of how you can create a
nurturing environment for some of the
local population to be inspired by some
of this best average social innovators
who come to that region but they it's
their involvement they're getting
involved and inspired to address the
problems of their region if you were to
depend on outsiders coming in that
problem will not go away the solution
that you develop
one solutions so what you can do what
action for India intends to do for this
region of innovation is to work with the
partner organizations we thanks for
giving them low interest present we
don't speed in terms of identifying the
corporate social responsibility
divisions of corporates to give ya the
financial resources to some of the
results shop there so the focus is very
clearly in length the talent from the
ground up in that region so that will
take time I mean the people i mentioned
you next job honestly there's a berkeley
glad they can come here digital green is
an MIT cutting but i'm glad but not all
the way of it is that like that it's
inspiring to see them yeah say no to
these kind of comforts in Silicon Valley
or elsewhere so there is a kind of a
search for meaning the reason why they
do it is again you have the financial
element is one dimension but when you
see the impacted such level I mean we
can Gandhi is kind of making a
difference with life so tens of
thousands of farmers in India how does
it compare by sitting and we had a
despot and do we couldn't chop it oracle
or whatever else he was working before
so it's that that drying them it's not
as if via the sacrificing it's a
difference cualquier search for meaning
and value that they can hope you gained
okay I'm afraid that we're out of time
for the formal part of the session and I
know we have to shut down the auditorium
we've got some refreshments outside and
hope you'll join our panelists here
radhika and Sanjay Sam thank you so much
for participating remotely everyone
please give me if you're closing
comments can you just speak to the
audience and suggest in terms of for
them to meaningfully engage with the
social innovators in india and the
ecosystem inhibitors in india what would
be how can the minute we engage just
some closing comments I'd I think you
need to learn a little more about what's
going on in India I find a lot of people
are very fervent about what's really
half they rely on the media and press
which only talks about cricket bollywood
and gothic
feel free to go beyond them and see what
exactly is happening on the ground then
connect with one or two or five people
in your areas of interest either in
terms of geography in terms of subject
in terms of age group or whatever and
build that Network and you could be here
be of great help you don't have to be
there I think the idea is to really
network with people off equal interest
similar interest but before that you can
really learn about what's going on there
educate yourself I would suggest that be
a good starting point and India is going
to be around he has going to continue to
grow at eight to ten percent for next 25
years guarantee leaving aside few
glitches here and there because there
are five hundred fifty million young
below age of 25 because we gotta create
10 to 15 million new jobs every year
here after here we have no options but
do it and it is a virgin territory so
there is too much to do technology is
the answer and talent is required from
all over the world that's the message
thank you okay Thank You Simon thanks
everybody
you